laughs Gomez - we're welcome back to the
bass playthrough of YouTube of all games
of all time
oh my god you're welcome you are so
welcome
look Edgar's crying he's crying dogs
don't cry but he's crying
that's how beautiful this is he went
through crying surgery so I [ __ ] up we
all [ __ ] up every once in a while
don't tell me you never [ __ ] up like I
lost I lost no meal all right what do
you want me to say I'm sorry
well I am I'm sorry for reals uh let's
again stop crying seriously it's getting
weird all right well you know what a new
beginning a new beginning that's not the
saying is it Chad is loving this change
like yeah she's still in her panties and
they're both texting awkwardly just
thinking about trains while texting that
they're both thinking about trades what
is what are the coincidence you think
about llama
will she think about the llama will she
think about the llama
no she thought of something else
well Chad is in a great [ __ ] mood
let's give them a house let's give them
a preset houses I'm tired I don't want
to spend a lot of time there you go
that's a [ __ ] kitchen bathroom
bedroom and there's a living room our
house is complete just kidding this is
our house it's all green where's Chen
Chen we're like oh it's already reading
Kira this reading Tumblr smut remember
that one time I tack your eyes like this
like this do you remember any Budo poop
and abruzzo yeah that was good times
Chinese like a resist touching the bully
resisted I gotta say there's there's
something strange about our house I
don't know what it is just reminds me of
something
well I guess it's all in my head it
wouldn't be no mill without any gnomes
so this looks great however there is
something about it that I'm not entirely
sure if it's a good idea
he's reading children's books the first
unicorn oh that's a classic this has to
be the best house in all of Sims ever
alright I give them some more toys to
play with Chan what is that Alright
punching bag punch out your sorrow ten
oh you look good
Robert yeah eyeballing grab a [ __ ] oh
wow yeah you teach it Wow oh damn calm
down Chang I knew we had a lot of
angering in her eye she'll have to go
jogging as she goes back and she sleeps
on the couch and she peed on the couch
thank you
what happened they crashed
don't tell me didn't save oh come on oh
my god I built the perfect house and
this is how you pick this game sometimes
I swear to God you know what fine I'll
reconstruct it oh this is gonna look
great this is even better than the gnome
thing now this is the quality house best
house ever
there's no it and there's no door so
that end room same yeah it has this
beautiful mouth maybe not a beautiful
but it's beautiful
why don't they want to enter the hell is
wrong with you guys
all right it's time for Chan to go on
adventures it's been a while let's
invade someone's house because that's
what changes are there looks like
there's people inside let's go in we are
in yeah yet to notice chance presence
there's a whole family in this place
Chinese China I think they're a little
too young for you great Chinese a
pedophile it's talking about it we have
inflatable dildos to them ten-chan what
are you doing no Chan this is not
appropriate Chad Chad no this is not
appropriate they don't even care they
just keep going always asleep come on
can you go to a stranger's houses Oh God
chan sits down with two drinks is that
oh yeah I'm about to get to first base
oh wait I was supposed to get one of the
drinks to hurry god damn it which one
that I put the drugs in I got damn it I
forgot I better drink both so Monique
it's our crackhead
so much pain inside and I can tell
you're still fat no well Chinese having
the time of his life
anaconda is drinking milk reevaluating
her life she's still drinking that milk
huh I think you have plenty of milk
already if you know what I'm saying I'm
sorry
that looks great
Shino so hard and all the sudden chance
Oh alone lonely Chinese lonely no Chan
what happened China
alright well let's go back to an
anaconda oh she's at work well I kinda
we heard boom booty jiggle voice your
fleets since she said word what the [ __ ]
she robbing our own house god damn it I
do wait oh my gosh and pick the pink bed
Chen what are you doing Chen Chan for
[ __ ] sake he's oh god what happened
what is he doing complaining about
problems it still says anaconda isn't
worried [ __ ] that [ __ ] I wish my job was
like that oh wait my job is play games
actually
the giant gnome shall be seen from space
wow what a great placement of a gnome
well at least it's easy to find our
house now so there's just some weird
bugs saying that she's at work even
though she's not so we're getting paid
for her to be at her job
except she's at home sleeping yeah if
only that glitch would happen in real
life
oh it's this house it's me
Lloyd I'm not that buff but what am i
doing sitting alone in this kind of sad
flat hey hey hey forty pie wanna take a
shower with me I'll just go ready enjoy
me whenever I want
look she can technically look at his
eyes come on Felix that is the face of
someone who doesn't want to look at an
ass it's really waving them around you
know turn it off you focus Felix all
right you know what I gotta get in this
episode here hope you bros enjoyed
watching if you did thankfully me like
as always and thank you for being a bro
as always stay awesome ruff